não sou só as idéias que inspiram né
mas principalmente às pessoas porque as
pessoas que você escolhe para ser seu
exemplo de vida vão definir quem você é
lembro que um dos momentos onde eu mais
precisei de um monte de o modelo
inspirador foi durante as jornadas de
junho de 2013
eu a gente estava no nosso apartamento e
muita gente muito bagunçada das ruas
bomba sendo estouradas helicópteros
passando e então foi nesse momento que
eu percebi que a gente não pode fechar
os olhos por que tá acontecendo em volta
a gente tem que se entregar e realmente
fazer o que a gente pode então em uma
festa de aniversário do na escola do meu
filho acabei conhecendo a luiza helena
trajano
ela falou que tava começando esse grupo
de mulheres a fazer propostas para o
brasil né o grupo apartidário e que ela
se cansaram de reclamar e que ele queria
propor soluções para o brasil melhor
então percebi que aquele era atender o
chamado que eu tinha sentido antes no
apartamento quando estava toda aquela
confusão
isso já fazem dois anos hoje já temos
mais de 500 mulheres participando e são
pessoas incríveis não só profissionais
mas modelos de seres humanos então
continuando a buscar modelos se inspire
e inspirações
eu acabei ouvindo falar da singularity
university que é uma instituição que
fica na nasa e ele se dedicou a usar a
tecnologia mas focado pra ajudar um
bilhão de pessoas nos próximos dez anos
foi uma experiência incrível é junto com
esses grandes pensadores do vale do
silício
mas eu percebi que faltava a energia
feminina valores que são considerados
femininos como cooperação empatia mas
que os homens também estão desenvolvendo
hoje em dia felizmente
então a gente fundou e nation que essa
plataforma de cloud funny dedicada a
mostrar ou modos e também agregar as
pessoas pra que cada um possa ajudar a
resolver os grandes problemas do mundo
relacionados à educação energia água
comida comunidade segurança saúde
política espaço e mentalidade
a gente colocou no ar no mês passado e
alguns dos projetos que estão sbac eu
ele foi é uma idéia de uma ligeira e ana
que se formou e colômbia e nova york
ela quer fazer esse filme para inspirar
as pessoas e conscientiza da situação
que existe na áfrica onde muitas meninas
são sequestrados para se casar na idade
de 10 a 13 anos
outro projeto é a alcione albanese ela
estava aqui mais cedo e a gente quer
ajudar a trazer pessoas do mundo inteiro
pra colaborar e pra se inspirar por ela
também
mas o projeto é o space for girls que é
inspirado pela no chan sário anush eu
conheci na singularity e ela foi a
primeira turista espacial a primeira
pessoa que consegue civil que conseguiu
ir para o espaço
então com esse filme a gente quer
inspirar mais meninas a se interessar
por tecnologia também expandir os seus
horizontes
outro projeto que vai entrar no ar nos
próximos dias é o da aliança de
misericórdia
é o projeto incrível que eles fazem aqui
com a qual as pessoas que moram na rua
então eles se dedicam só voluntários e
ajudou mais de 20 mil pessoas por mês a
se alimentar e também ter estrutura para
sair da rua interessante
o modelos exemplo de vida podem ser
dados por indivíduos mas também por
grupos e agosto a gente esteve no japão
a comitiva da da ong mulheres do brasil
pra ajudar a inspirar as mulheres do
japão
por quê adicionalmente é uma cultura
muito onde as mulheres depois que se
casam vôo de trabalhar é 60% deixa de
seu trabalho e fica só olhando de casa
não foi muito emocionante porque pessoas
do mundo inteiro estava lá para discutir
maneiras de incluir as mulheres e fazer
com que elas brilhem porque a gente
acredita que todos o ri e uma sociedade
onde as mulheres brilho
os modelos também podem vir bem de perto
da sua família
os modelos que eu levo comigo é o da
minha avó
ela chegou aqui no brasil veio do japão
no brasil quando tinha quatro anos e ela
me ensinou a ser sempre alegre
não importa o que aconteça então procuro
sempre chegar os exemplos que estão à
sua volta
sejam eles próximos ou distantes e
também seja sempre o seu melhor porque
você já é um exemplo para as pessoas que
estão à sua volta
muito obrigado